- Alright I've got one more
gift for you this hour.
A sweet story to give you
all the holiday feels.
This is what I'm liking.
(short guitar riff)
(crowd cheering)
More than 65 years ago,
a then high school graduate Anita,
received a gift from her mom's friend.
Her very first Santa Claus trinket.
Anita fell in love.
After that friends and
family started buying her
more and more.
And then she bought more herself.
Then random strangers
started sending them to her.
She's now amassed over 3,500 Santas,
all carefully set up in a
makeshift museum inside her
Alabama home.
Over the years,
she's had hundreds of people come to visit
and bask in the magic of her collection.
We have Anita on the line right now.
Hi Anita.
- Hey Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
It looks so magical where you are.
I wish I was there in person.
It's nice to meet you.
You must really love Santa.
- I do.
It brings such joy and cheer to people.
Men, women and children.
And my children believe in Santa.
And they're in their fifties.
I told them when they were little,
if you don't believe
in Santa you don't get
nothing from Santa Claus under the tree.
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
- I mean, my children do as well.
And they still hear the
bell for Polar Express.
So can you show us around a little?
- Absolutely.
This is Huntsville, Alabama Santa museum.
- I love it.
- These are toys.
These are all toys.
And over here are bubble blowers
and other things.
Furbies.
And around over here,
is my little Santa Bill.
Got it in Cocoa, Florida in 1955
from a friend of my mother's.
That started my collection,
but I didn't know I was going to collect,
But I guess I'm a collector.
Anyhow, this is my favorite.
This is,
Jesus with Santa Claus,
and it's a music box.
And over here,
this big old Santa,
he scared my granddaughter to death
because he dances,
and he sings,
and he moves.
And I had to unplug him
and bring her up here
and let her hold his hand
to see that he was not real.
And I have one that-
the big one that playing the piano
and the big one in the hammock.
They are Coca-Cola stuffed Santas.
This one rides in my Cadillac,
in the back seat with a seat belt.
And my husband will not
go to church with me
in my car with that Santa.
So I said,
well you just drive your own car.
(laughing)
So we both went to church,
but in separate cars.
He thought I was nuts.
Merry Christmas.
- Thank you so much Anita,
for joining us.
I love your whole museum.
It's so cool.
It's magical.
And it makes everyone happy.
And I'm liking your posts right now,
all right?
(crowd cheering)
And Anita,
that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot pen makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly.
Just like you ma'am.
So they're going to give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Well thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you for sharing.
- Absolutely.